hey guys it is a second of July today my
name is jeff mcdonald and you are tuned
in to gamespot news if you wondering why
I keep wearing jumpers it's because
Australia is praising if you're
wondering why I said jump is instead of
sweaters it's because I'm Australian all
right I think that covers the song
Nintendo may be getting themselves on
track to sell more we use this year as
they've decided they can win the console
war with stella content Nintendo of
America exec Reggie fiza may told IGN
it's all about content for us if you
look back at what we were able to do
during the weed generation what we're
able to do with TS what we're doing now
with three dias it's about content it's
about content that widens the footprint
for the platform it's about content that
drives the install base and as we do
that and guess what people buy hardware
fiza may also reckon that wii u owners
will encourage their friends to pick up
the console but however the sales are
driven nintendo adamant that they're far
from giving up on the wii u xbox is phil
spencer has said he's totally cool with
bungee saddling up to playstation in
regard to destiny everybody likes a bit
of melodrama but apparently microsoft is
alright with not owning Bungie Studios
any longer and seeing it go off and find
happiness with other publishers the
games alpha was only available on
playstation 4 and the beta will make its
way there before it lands on xbox one
there's also a special destiny ps4
bundle coming from Sony and well you see
the patent nonetheless Phil Spencer is
said they just want to see Bungie filled
a great game EA exec Peter Moore has
said that while he reckons we are in the
Golden Age of gaming the industry does
need to embrace change more told
Gamesindustry international that there
are new business models appearing in
gaming including free to play and that
he sees a lot of pushback on these
models from some core gamers more does
say though that he thinks gamers will
come around to what he's calling
industry disruptions like free to play
and microtransaction model he's also
said something about a canoe and since I
love it when execs pull for elongated
metaphors here's his thoughts on whether
gamers can make peace with the changing
industry I don't think anybody has to
like
I think that's where it goes it's like
me I get grumpy about some things but if
the river of progress is flowing and I'm
trying to paddle my canoe in the
opposite direction and eventually i'm
just gonna lose out from the perspective
of what needs to happen in this industry
we need to embrace the fact that
billions of people are playing games now
sweet well if that canoe one got you
going sledgehammer have all this one for
a literary device although according to
you guys it lands a little closer to
hyperbole the dev have said that call of
duty advanced warfare is going from
photo realistic visuals and they reckon
people won't even realize it's a game
activision released behind-the-scenes
video so you can judge for yourself but
they've said that by using refined
emotion capture and putting extra effort
into displaying every movement of a
character even within an exosuit the
graphics will in their words blow people
away blow people with low people love
you oh oh my god that's a game that's
crazy let me know what you think is
advanced warfare so far in that comment
section down below or if you prefer you
can chat to me on my twitter where i'm
at just mcdonald those are all the
things that i want to tell you about
today i will be back tomorrow and be
sure to float freely down your own
personal river of progress i'll see you
soon